the roman catholic archbishop of
washington d.c will make history
tomorrow
pope francis will formally add wilton
gregory to the college of cardinals the
first black american to hold that rank
he's been an outspoken voice on some of
the most pressing
issues facing his church and this
country chris livesay spoke to gregory
and joins us now from rome chris great
to see you good morning
good morning michelle wilton gregory is
in rome the first
black american to receive a red cap
and as he self-isolates we spoke to the
cardinal designate
about some of the pressing issues of our
time from pre-sex abuse
to race as well as his tense
relationship
with the white house he was named
a cardinal gregory
without any warning were you surprised
i i'm very much surprised i got a phone
call
at 6 30 in the morning that's how i
found out
trail blazing since the sixth grade
wilton gregory converted to catholicism
in 1958
as his parochial school in chicago
underwent integration
and white flight there were white kids
transferring out
and black kids transferring in so at the
end of the sixth grade
there were then only about six or seven
white kids
left and the rest were african-american
students
since entering the priesthood a keystone
of his ministry has been welcoming
diversity including the lgbtq plus
community but he really stepped up as a
leader amid the church's
biggest disgrace priest sex abuse
in our work toward protecting minors
while leading the u.s bishops conference
he championed a zero
tolerance policy to remove offending
clerics from ministry
and last year pope francis named him
archbishop of washington d.c
i will rebuild your trust
the same year one of his predecessors
theodore mccarrick
was defrocked for sex abuse culminating
this month
in a groundbreaking vatican report let's
be honest chris
it revealed some awful
events and huge mistakes
on the part of church leadership
but it's the leadership at the white
house he's most forcefully challenged
calling it baffling and reprehensible
when president trump visited the saint
john paul ii national shrine in
washington
a day after protesters were forced away
so the president
bible in hand could pose in front of
saint john's episcopal church
gregory hopes his relationship with
president-elect joe biden
will be different despite their
differences
i want to begin whatever conversations
ensue in a positive
vein rather than in an adversarial
mode among those differences
abortion joe biden the first catholic
president since john f kennedy
is under a lot of pressure from the
catholic community for his party's
support
of a woman's right to choose vlad
all right chris lipsay in rome for us
thank you chris